chaque être humain a un instinct de base
pour s'entraider si un randonneur se
perd dans les montagnes les gens coordonnent
une recherche si un tremblement de terre rase la
ville les gens du monde entier envoient
des fournitures d'urgence
cet instinct se retrouve dans toutes les cultures
sans
exception vers 4  :30 heures du matin nos satellites ont
détecté une tempête s'approchant du
site de la mission Ares 3 sur Mars la tempête s'est
aggravée
et nous n'avons pas d'autre choix que d'interrompre la
mission mais pendant l'évacuation l'
astronaute Mark Watney a été tué
J'entre dans ce journal pour l'enregistrement  c'est
Mark Watney et je suis toujours en vie,
évidemment je n'ai aucun moyen de contacter la NASA
avec mes coéquipiers mais même si je le pouvais, il
faudrait quatre ans pour qu'une autre
mission habitée m'atteigne et je vais avoir
conçu les 31 derniers jours donc  face à
des obstacles écrasants, il ne me reste qu'une
seule option, je vais devoir faire de la
science, d'
accord, faisons le calcul, je dois
trouver comment faire pousser quatre ans de nourriture
ici sur un pla  net où rien ne pousse mais
si je ne peux pas trouver un moyen d'entrer en
contact avec la NASA, rien de tout cela n'a d'importance de
toute façon Houston, sachez que nous avons un
message vidéo, il s'adresse à tout l'
équipage mais mon dieu
marque ce qui est encore en vie
ton visage Neil Armstrong nous sommes
laissés en ligne allons chercher notre garçon
c'est quelque chose de gentil que j'ai rejeté donc nous
parlons de mutinerie et si nous gâchons
le rendez-vous d'approvisionnement tu meurs si nous gâchons
la terre la gravité assiste nous mourons l'
espace ça ne marche pas  Je ne coopère
pas avec toi qu'à un moment donné,
tout ira au sud pour toi
et tu vas dire c'est
ça c'est comme ça que je suis
est-il possible qu'il soit encore en vie